morbius est un personnage merveilleux qui a été
une partie importante de l'univers,
il est brillant, je suis guéri,
il est enfin possible qu'il soit fort,
il a des pouvoirs uniques
mais ses pouvoirs semblent hors de son
contrôle,
ce qui se passe,
j'adore l'opportunité de faire quelque chose de
transformationnel.  Je suis devenu quelque chose
de différent,
c'était un rôle physique très intense,
plus biaisé, plus fragile, puis
plus monstrueux,
ce super-méchant super-héros
mettant à l'écran un nouveau personnage Marvel
qui n'avait jamais été à l'écran auparavant,
ce sera amusant de voir où nous pourrions  allez-y, il y a
un réseau d'opportunités
plus de bs en exclusivité au cinéma
nouvelle bande-annonce demain
vous